fanno già però mai una palazzina con
cortile interno
praticamente ogni notte si sentivano
moda un altro appartamento aprire la
finestra della sua camera urlare no
perché direttore del catania fa del male
a nessuno tipo lanciare i vasi per terra
però invasi e meno rompi qualcosa invece
li semplice ciao ragazzi benvenuti e non
a puntata di vita buttata il tema di
oggi è viaggi assurdi l'ospite di questa
puntata ha condiviso con me un viaggio
assurdo non tanto per la meta quanto per
il fatto che con questa persona non ci
sarei andato manco a fare la spesa
alice quasi che saluto e me ne vado per
chi non lo sapesse abbiamo fatto express
insieme eravamo la coppia degli amici
[Musica]
quindi oppure c'era un bagno avevano
riempito e quindi puzzava allora sono
varie le teorie è quello che sappiamo è
che 12v hanno creato il panico
prima hanno riempito l'atmosfera ok
manestrini vacanza una settimana con due
miei amici che una coppia omosessuale un
certo punto un mio amico mi dice
siamo in bagno telo sussidio io prendo
un lieto che non fare troppo rumore
tutto sta che il volume di pagar massimo
e cose perché talmente tutto a mamma ti
capisco benissimo è successa la stessa
cosa a me durante le filippine ma che
devi sempre su questo filippis e mi
ricordo su quel pavimento io da solo col
mio zaino mentre lei celebrava la
vittoria della prima puntata come guarda
disilluso proprio ti conosco talmente
tanto che sapevo che avresti fatto
questa possibilità lo sai che è successo
è scorso ma non si vergognava 26
vergognato ma soprattutto la diminuzione
sono il telefono ed è lontano insomma
signora che entra nel bus richiede tempo
degli odori assurdi deve andare in bagno
io mi alzo per farla passare
scende e mi sporca dino de antoni
rivolto era rimasto lui stiamo porterà
alto è presente quelli che passano con
la chiave ti rigano la macchina questa
qui diriga pantaloni per mille volte che
gli allargata la macchina e si distrugge
la cia non aveva addosso un po una
vecchia agita delle superiori quando una
delle coppiette più famose della
classifica furiosamente lei essendo la
mia migliore amica dell'epoca mi invita
a dormire in camera sua
quando durante la notte sento stringermi
sbagliato un certo punto però sento
anche di qualcosa spingersi verso le mie
parti basse
i girali botto e trovai il suo fidanzato
totale è venuto totalmente pilato che
tentava di butera
ero in viaggio verso casa in treno con
mio padre all'epoca avevo 14 15 anni e
vive a quello c erano due ragazzi
la situazione è questa mio padre che mi
parla e dice allora arriviamo a casa va
in bagno di spogli di laghi la patatina
quindi ma scusa fatti il trio alice mi
raccomando adesso a casa è pomata per le
emorroidi una volta mentre ero in
viaggio con mio padre di famiglia che mi
davano per l'area torto con le valigie
lei teneva in mano nel manico della
valigia che si era staccata dalla
valigia e così la vaca minare la valigia
era rimasta in contemporanea dove andare
c'era un trolley
quindi lei rimasta col braccio proteso
indietro con una caviglia quelle serrati
per i noti fatti negramaro debito
laterano spagna se il matrimonio di mia
zia e graziotti era in macchina con il
padre e mia zia imbottigliati nel
traffico
mi scappa tra cui questo o quel periodo
in spiaggia d'oro nei secchielli con la
grafica e questa è quella volta è la
quale che in macchina di una persona che
non conoscevo dentro un secchiello
eticamente degli aceri sul gozzo nipote
senta è stato un matrimonio bellissimo
fatto uno stage in bulgaria allora ero
nella mensa a pranzare con i miei
colleghi è un mio collega di fatto è un
frutto che io ho fatto di testa è stato
portato una banana al ristorante
un'altra volta e la camera vi fa perché
tempo il bicchiere
io ho fatto ricci con la camera ci sono
anche insomma in pusteria si vuol dire
che non vuoi che deciso no
lei mi ha risposto alla domanda della
vita che problemi a mia nonna che quando
le dico non voglio mangiare ancora legni
portale mangiare è bollata ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video se
avete altre esperienze da raccontare
fatemelo sapere qua sotto con un
commento io ali ti ringrazio per essere
venuto ospite su prego prego guarda dopo
pechino per te questo ed altro fa ma
meraviglioso sentite io vi mando un
bacio grande naturalmente ci vediamo al
prossimo video ciao ciao